hallo zusammen ich wollte euch nur kurz
bescheid geben dass es im märz eventuell
minimal ruhiger wird auf einem kanal es
wird weiterhin jeden sonntag um 10 uhr
ein rezept video geben und mittwochs
gibt es dann halt auch mal ein shorts
rezept das ist dann dieses format und es
liegt einfach daran dass wir uns für die
ramadan reihe im april vorbereiten und
ihr wisst ja bei mir ist es immer das
ist ganz wichtig qualität statt
quantität daher schraube ich lieber ein
bisschen zurück und bereite mich dann er
ideal für die ramadan reihe vor und da
gibt es dann drei rezept wie du es jede
woche ein monat lang und darauf freue
ich mich schon richtig wir sehen uns
dann beim nächsten video am sonntag und
wenn ihr mögt abonniert auch gerne den
block kanal von hamza und mir da gibt's
nämlich jeden sonntag um 18 uhr neues
video bis dahin tschüss